il ya un petit événement aujourd'hui qui
est sympathique c'est l'anniversaire de
bassam à castres benjamin castaldi qui
évolue très bon mais plutôt comme les
copains on va gérer parce que tu vas
pouvoir gagner un cadeau mais quand je
vous dis un cadeau mais non mais un
cadeau exceptionnel lors si benjamin
normal ça m'a pas sa maman chérie
affaire des fadettes et à l'inévitable
août et les chéris non mais tu chéris ne
dit rien ne dit orianne bord des chéris
mais benjamin castaldi
il a un truc il adore faire ce jeu féret
que la patate de forain benjamin vous
allez avoir toutes deux coups de poing
avant de comprendre a le plus fort nous
le plus gros score tous les chroniqueurs
passeront si vous faites plus que tous
les chroniqueurs c'est à dire si aucun
chroniqueur n'arrive à vous battre vous
gagnerez pour votre anniversaire
cette voiture attention c'est parti
vas-y tu ne me donnes pas trop on
prendra le meilleur score
au départ alors attends je vois la
question est-ce que tu prends celui là
où est-ce que tu tant d'autres choses
il est bien ce que t'as jamais fait
autant d'égards attendent à 500-700 72
que je vais pas faire tout l'ancien
régime a fait le quand même on va voir
comment c'est agathe ses morts la veille
à gap
c'est mort benjamin il est tout
émoustillé merci regardez la balle et
les médailles m6 parce qu'elle prive
tête dans la gueule face aux événements
suez avait quand même
ouais nul non oui c'est nul je gagne ta
me toi tu va baisser
tu vas te blesser djama fécond à 7,560
je sais plus non mais faut quand même
qu'on m'a fait vraiment régis suis un
peu froid 3 772 mhz a dit gilles madone
est question
la story benjamin castaldi repart avec
la voiture
ces outils il va plus bas du jour hier
572 haras qu'il est pas mal mais
aujourd'hui il est pas mal mais
aujourd'hui non gens me sens mieux
maintenant jour mis au monde cinq ans au
respect de l'autre
attention même fait 66 ans nathalie
isabelle normalement pour l'instant la
voiture est à benjamin castaldi frileux
blague
si vous bâti benjamin castaldi il n'aura
pas gagné la voiture si vous perdez il
repartira avec la voiture vient voir
suspense isabelle on me dit on me dit
qu'ils avaient les blessés ah ouais donc
on va appeler on va payer son remplaçant
à bentiba chimiques taper j'appelle
arsène bulard you know
le champion du monde des lourds légers
[Applaudissements]
772 frérot de calme g si je dois acheter
cette voiture pour castaldi jeune et je
suis fait ces annonces alors si tu me
lis pas la presse verte à la ceinture à
toi pas dire celle là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu le bas si tu le bas du coup si tu
m'a battu remparts avec la ceinture
comme si c est j adore quand c'est amy
ceux-là nous 143 à tuer ta voiture il a
battu tu vas tu aimes ça mais 105,42
bien de ça alors
[Applaudissements]
et